a former store engineer at Google faces
criminal charges for allegedly stealing
company secrets about self-driving cars
and giving them to over a major
competitor the federal indictment filed
yesterday in Silicon Valley escalates
the high-stakes fight to reshape the
future of Transportation Kris Van Cleave
is here with details now of the case
Kris how serious are these charges good
morning Anthony 11 douse key is being
charged with 33 counts of attempted
theft of trade secrets prosecutors
compared these allegations to stealing
the crown jewels of self-driving car
technology all of us generally speaking
are free to move from job to job what we
cannot do is stuff our pockets on the
way out the door
according to the federal indictment
Anthony Levin Dow skee allegedly
downloaded and stole approximately
fourteen thousand documents related to
Google's self-driving car project before
he abruptly quit and went to work for
uber US Attorney David Andersen is
prosecuting the case I think the
indictment bespeaks a arrogance that you
know Silicon Valley is the kind of place
where because we're all here to move
fast and and break rules we can break
the law that's where we draw the line
Levin Dow ski is regarded by many as a
legend in Silicon Valley and created the
sensor technology at the heart of most
self-driving cars in a statement Levin
Dow skis attorney says his client didn't
steal anything from anyone and none of
the files in question ever went to Ober
in a civil suit last year uber agreed to
pay Google's self-driving car company
whammo two hundred and forty five
million dollars to settle the dispute
over the technology but the judge
overseeing that case recommended a
criminal investigation leading to these
new charges CBS News contributor Nick
Thompson there have been other stories
of trade secret theft but I don't think
there's ever been anything quite like
this remember Google was the first major
company with this idea they were talking
about self-driving cars before everybody
and now it's not so clear who has the
lead and there are lots of explanations
for this but part of it is they they
entrusted the operation
clémence bow ski each of the 33 counts
carries a maximum 10 year sentence plus
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
potential fines uber is not named in the
indictment but says it's cooperating
with the ongoing investigation
Levin Dow Ski has pleaded not guilty
well that message you can break rules
you can break fast and break fast break
things but you can't break the law it'll
be interesting a lot of people in
Silicon Valley watching this case yeah
hopping off your neighbors paper here
allegedly yeah it seems like there would
be a paper trail so mm-hmm digital trail
and he should know because they worked
at Google yeah that's right